the Joe Rogan experience how long does
it take to develop a vaccine for this
coronavirus wait you know when I'm asked
that question I don't mean to sound glib
again but I can make a vaccine for an
overnight the question is is it safe and
effective hmm and that's the challenge
we have right now questions about how do
you make community to a corona virus and
what kind of vaccines you have to have
that brings in all the different parts
of the immune system so we don't know
that yet so some of this research is
going to have to be basic to that the
second thing we have to worry about of
safety there's a condition in humans
called antibody dependent enhancement
8ee and it turns out that if you have no
antibody or immune response you'll get
the disease if you have a lot you're
protected but if you have this
in-between level and then you get the
disease it actually enhances the disease
immune response is really destructive
and in fact there was just a couple
years ago a major recall of dengue
vaccine a type of vaccine leaders from
mosquito infection in the Philippines
were kids who got the vaccine actually
made just a little bit of antibody and
when they got the real disease it made
him a lot sicker and so we found with
the 2003 SARS vaccine that there was an
ad e component to it when we made it in
animals and so we're gonna have to
really study this to be sure it's safe
and as you said earlier you know we can
surely make mistakes we don't you know
we needed to I mean we can not - and so
I think between getting the
effectiveness and the safety data
together were years out I mean maybe
years yeah this is not going to happen
soon yeah you know it's wishful thinking
you know every time I mean I go back to
SARS in 2003 and look at every event
Zika 2015 we said Oh we'll have a
vaccine for it in no time here we are
five years later and we've no vaccine
and so this is one of the challenges we
have we have to complete the job you
know it's like we start on something and
then we forget that it's important
because it kind of goes away for a while
but only to come back and so this is
part of that picture we talked about and
this is what Peter Hotez talks a lot
about you know we gotta finish the job
on these things you know I worry that
we'll get through this situation and
then people say all we're done and then
we'll forget until the next one
comfortable
and so so this is where vaccine research
and development is really important how
do they test for safety so once they
come up with a potential vaccine how do
they make sure that it's safe well you
do it gradually first of all you put it
into animals to see and you know enough
about them how their immune responses
what do they do
then you put it into a few humans 30
humans you know they volunteer willingly
knowing to see what kind of reactions
they have well I would just take really
bad people that are in jail and practice
on them well I I don't know if that's
doable here in this country without
their informed consent
so I'll just wrump can fix that anybody
if we have a shot of doing that with any
president it's wrong just start with
rapists yeah so anyway the bottom line
though is is that then they gradually
work their way up to larger studies
where you know if something happens one
every thousand people you have to study
a lot of people before you know the
chance that you might find that right
you do it on 30 people so that's why
it's gonna take a while and you know
they'll test it on more and more people
and they're going as fast as they can
it's not like there's anybody dragging
their feet it's just that you know I
joke in lycée it's like if the Iowa
farmer wanted to harvest corn in half
the time it doesn't mean by planting
twice as many acres he can do that you
know plant in April you still can't
harvest October that's a good thing
that's what this is it's going to take
us this long to get this vaccine
[Applause]